tony boisdon a préparé une petite
surprise ses clients ce pâtissier
propose une nouvelle galette la dernière
d'une longue série
et les clients ne se font pas prier pour
testé l'invention du pâtissier s'est
risqué de d'en deviner pas droit parce
qu'ils croient si je vous dis qu'il ya
les haricots rouges
non non non non haricots rouges
si je vous le dis c'est des haricots
rouges
je ne crois pas
même après l'étonnement des premiers
instants certains clients se laissent
séduire vous l'a étonné un petit peu
votre famille aussi oui là je ne dirais
pas ça va le laisser manger mais pour en
arriver là c'est le pâtissier a
longuement travaillé sa recette
alors c'est ça qui fait la différence et
l'assaisonnement alors tout à fait c'est
ça la saison 2 de citron de cannelle de
vanille avec aussi du sucre ce qui amène
maintenant à la gouge quelque chose de
sucré quelque chose qui devient déguste
à témoin adc en détournant les haricots
rouges traditionnellement servis avec de
la salaison en martinique
tony boisdon a voulu ouvrir de nouveaux
horizons en gourmands une idée qui lui
est venue en voyageant seuls qui peuvent
tuer des bugs bunny adia tic
il faut beaucoup de transformations des
fois avec des choses qu'on pense pas
donc à partir de là à travers des
voyages
j'ai vu certaines choses ici c'est de
les refaire à la sauce à la sauce de
chez nous chaque année cette boulangerie
propose de nouvelles saveurs innover
suscité la curiosité de ses clients pour
mieux se distinguer des grandes surfaces
c'est le secret pour résister à la
concurrence